you need to know if something can be
built you don't have to know how to
build it yourself
you just have to know um that it can be
done and that
if you can get the money from silicon
valley or something
you can hire the the engineers to build
it for you
[Music]
wes butville thank you so much for
joining on 20 minute leaders welcome to
my show how are you
hello fine i'm calling from los angeles
and the weather is cloudy
wonderful well i'm calling from tel aviv
it's been cloudy all week
but where's i the reason why i'm so
excited to chat with you besides for the
besides your energy and enthusiasm is i
get to talk to an inventor in front of
me and i love talking to inventors
because i i consider myself an inventor
in many capacities but but the way that
you've done it over the past
uh over the past years and holding
patents and creating these innovative
technologies
based on real problems and i think it's
fascinating so was
give me a little bit of background as to
who you are and why do you consider
yourself an
inventor oh um i came to america
in 1983 to los angeles to get my phd in
theoretical physics
and from caltech in la and
i i did that and then i stayed in los
angeles ever
since and so i've lived here much longer
than i have in australia where i'm from
and i'm a first generation australian um
i was born in malaysia
i'm chinese mostly and i have a french
surname it's one of these accidents of
history but you know
in stanford um you guys are used to that
dude you get people from everywhere
a hundred percent always how do you
stumble upon this idea of innovation and
invention
what does that even mean to you because
i i stumble on it that's the right way
to put it i'm trained as a physicist
i got two degrees in physics and then i
made my living after i got my phd
as a computer programmer because this
was 1989
and back just the web was born that year
and there were plenty of jobs for
programmers
but in 19 during the dot-com years i
joined a dot-com startup
and it failed like most of them did but
then i got hit with a startup bug
and i've been in the startup scene ever
since and in 2008
i i stopped programming i co i
programmed computers from 1979 to 2008
40 years i started fortran i entered in
java
but then i just i went into actually
filing
patent applications for myself and it
was
right now i have 20 u.s patents under my
own name
i'm single author on 19 of them and
and it's it's all engineering so i start
off with a physicist but now i'm an
engineer
but i i feel like i i want to do this
for the rest of my life i'm very lucky
because um for this yeah a lot of people
are not
in their jobs and i really am i feel
like i'm in grad school back at caltech
30 years ago
because i'm doing research and i'm doing
it for myself
where's that that's one of the most
inspiring things i've heard in more than
300 episodes
uh tell me a little bit about these
these inventions these patterns that you
oh okay what are some of them like um i
have my 20
patents uh in two groups the first group
of seven patents
it's on barcodes like qr codes two
dimensional barcodes
and my my patterns for that are to
control a screen a electronic screen a
flat screen that's near you
a big flat screen that shows an image
and the image shows a
barcode and so you take out your cell
phone and
you take a photo of the barcode and you
get on your
cell phone uh a web page and that web
page
has buttons you can click you know
things you can do and
you can control the big screen in front
of you the big flat screen
and okay now that's the abstract the
practical case is
in a if you're a pedestrian on the
street and you're looking at a shop
window
inside the shop window behind the glass
is a big flat screen
showing something for sale with a
barcode when you scan the barcode you
get a search box on your phone a webpage
the search box pretend it's google or
something and you type addresses
and then but when you hit return the
results are not shown on your phone
they're shown on the big flat screen
behind the glass
and so if it's a dress or a hat or shirt
you can see it life size
and you can search the shop's entire
inventory
that's important because it solves the
problem that stood 400 years
and ever since shockwindows were
invented um the shop window is too small
to show all the goods
so every few months a shop manager has
to refresh the window physically
right she puts in new new things well
now
she can still do that but now you can
you search
whatever you want and then it'll display
under in big size
that then that makes a lot of sense was
how do you stumble upon that invention
so
i want to take this and explore this a
little bit more broadly about what it
means to be an inventor
and and so what i would love to hear
from you is sort of with these
inventions
how did you how did you even think of
them because i'm guessing that you're
not too much into retail and fashion
you're not an expert in retail or
fashion so how do you go ahead and
create a patent
right that's right that's the hardest
and
still and the some the most mysterious
thing for anybody
unless you were thomas edison um he had
a thousand patents
but the hardest thing is that at the
core of the innovative process
and the good thing one thing is that you
you need a good
and technical education you don't have
to be an engineer or scientist but it
helps
but you need to know if something can be
built you don't have to know how to
build it yourself
you just have to know um that it can be
done and that
if you can get the money from silicon
valley or something
you can hire the the engineers to build
it for you
um but so i guess for me
with a barcode thing i imagined it um
and i got the patents on it
but i just um like a remote control of a
screen
that's what i was thinking of without
being able to touch it all
what i'm doing right now my main focus
on my most of my 13
other patterns an alternative to
domains or domain name system and um
domains were used in the 1970s because
when the internet was born there were no
domains so you would then like
email our login to like john at
and then you give an internet address
who's if you said ucla
but nobody wanted to remember that so
domains themselves were invented
so that people could write john ucla.edu
or john at stanford.edu
i didn't know that's why domains were
invented by the way um domains
actually are older than the web the web
is 1989
of the world wide web html 1989.
before that people had you know um
people
had email addresses at at stanford ucla
uh caltech and and also in hp so
um but yeah domain because the first
killer app
of the of the internet was probably
email and
email needed domain email helped create
domains and then
the second killer app was really up the
web
later on for sure so so then
talk to me a little bit about this about
more broadly this um
domain problem and why why do you need
13 content
to address them the domains or dns which
is domain name system
it was invented so that you did not have
to memorize an internet address
which were then like you know 10 or
15.25.128 something
it's meaningless even for engineers and
back then
when domains were invented the only
users of the web sending email
were the hardcore researchers there's no
money there were engineers and
professors and grad
students throughout the u.s so these
were serious people
um but even they could see the immediate
use of a domain name system
um you know mit.edu is simple to
remember
sure and so the things like this and so
in what i'm doing right now with this
thing called linkers which are
an alternative to domains um we face
i faced a similar problem of people
having to memorize
two long alphanumeric strings that
didn't really mean anything
but then i realized and so i remember
that day i was walking to a park in
pasadena
and i was just i just was thinking about
this problem then i realized that
we were we the human race were here
before in the 1970s and 80s
that then they had a problem of trying
to remember
internet addresses so you avoid that
problem dns is the solution to that
here they had something called deep
links which were used which were
actually
invented in silicon valley in the early
2010s
and i put it but the deep links are
these two long
strings one string is just like an app
id in an app store
but um nobody really remember wants to
remember an app id
even if you could of course yeah and so
i just came up with the idea of just
putting a label on it and i just had to
call the label something i couldn't call
it domains because that's not quite what
it is
so i just don't link it because like
link like linkedin and all that link
it's
it's a connection and and also
the big thing for mine was that right
now they use something called unicode
which you know about if your computer
program unicode is a way to represent
every written human language domains are
really a to z
because when they were invented late 70s
that's all we had unicode didn't exist
and so the american engineers who
invented dns
they weren't trying to um act against
other countries to discriminate against
other countries
they were just saying that because in
terms of domains you can't even for
european languages written in the roman
alphabet
um all the other european languages have
accents
so except the tilde over the end but you
can't do it
don't wait you can't do french german
italian none of them
let alone the other languages would use
different alphabets like
well like cyrillic greek hebrew you know
and
all no you just can't so right now
with my stuff with lincoln i start with
unicode which means i can do all the
languages
from scratch right now wow so what so
what does that actually how do you
actually see this unfold do you mention
that you've written a series of patents
to go about this even before we continue
with lincoln talk to me about the
process of writing a patent
you sit down and you have this idea how
does that actually work end to end
yeah oh okay actually i i taught classes
in this
like you know patenting your invention
yeah but exactly um
it turns out if you're an engineer and
if you were having a
an undergraduate degree in engineering
or science you can basically write a
pattern you have enough technical
training to do that
um because it's just like you're writing
like if you're a senior in
engineering you wrote you're writing a
term paper in your senior year
on some of your work in the lab the and
like when you when you're told to
pretend that
you're submitting it to an academic
journal and maybe you are maybe your
professor is
it's the same sort of thing that you
have to use formal language
but it you don't need to use any legal
language
despite what a patent attorney might say
to you and here's the thing like in
in san francisco when you use a patent
attorney everything's more expensive
there in san francisco you know
well you already did that no knew that
but um it could cost
easily five thousand dollars to file a
patent application and that's just
that's to pay the attorney and it's
about 500
to pay the government and then you you
wait oh but
if you are into startups you guys um one
of the things to do
the good thing to do is that if you have
an idea about a patent application
you if you have to you pay an attorney
or you do it yourself whatever
you file the application let's say next
week
and then but the government gets it but
nothing will happen for the next 18
months
so then you you would go with your with
your receipt you get a you know a serial
number with a patent application
sure and then use that to show like
investors angels and vcs
and you can build it out if you can
afford it like if it's a mechanical
thing if the software
because you have 18 months where nothing
will happen with your patent application
so that's the way to do it you should
not file like
just um you shouldn't build it first and
file because
you lose the time and time is everything
so what happens if you file a patent and
then within those 18 months you have
other people that are filing those
provisional patents
yeah on a similar idea well that's just
it okay that 18 months
you just don't know you you really don't
know don't know
the provisionals uh they aren't
published or the
or even the patents pending which is
what i do i do not file provisionals i
file
the full patents pending a patent
pending it's a bit more expensive but
anyway uh
for the 18 months your your application
won't be published so nobody else could
see it for 18 months
um but it also means you can't see so
you don't know
that in that next 18 months if somebody
else was actually did it uh early before
you
um right so it's a little bit
nerve-wracking especially if you have a
valuable
idea now yeah the now the following
is just like um empirical empirical but
put it this way um every in that 18
months every week
like for example when when you look at
this at the new patent application
they're published every week
if you don't see somebody else coming up
with your idea then every week the odds
and proof that your idea was the first
it's not a course but it's just it's
like playing the odds
of course especially and it increases
the odds that google and microsoft and
other big companies
have in your idea because once once they
have filed a patent application
they don't have to wait or they or you
once you get that receipt back from the
government
you can talk about it the next day right
18 right and so when you don't and
google or microsoft
if they have filed a patent application
like of the same
idea as yours like yesterday then today
they could just publish that they could
publish their themselves
they on their blogs they were allowed to
do that legally
but and they have all the money in the
world to to do that to scare people's
place
if they don't do they don't do that they
probably haven't done that
yeah i i love it i love that i i love
the rationale so wes tell me a little
bit about linkedit you've written
uh your your last few patents based on
this
on on the domain space and for my
opinion what you're trying to do is
you're trying to democratize the
these domains so that really we can use
unicode which really is any character
ever that we can that we have on our
computer to uh
to create those domains why do you why
are you doing that and what are the
possible implications
okay the the big first problem
is that uh for the last 20 years um the
top
dot-com domains that are english words
have been bought by people who speculate
and there's nothing wrong with that but
i'm just saying this is what they've
done
and today the speculators are called
domainers some of them do this full type
of living
so what does that mean what do they do
oh they bought like a domain like
these are the dot-com domains because
the most valuable domains right now
are still in the dot com of space
and so it'd be like reason.com or
ramen.com or curry.com
things with commercial value um by the
way
why is that why is dot com valuable
mainly because that's what people are
used to
or is there that's the only reason right
right now
right and so but there's no intrinsic
reason
for this okay but um as a result of that
there were now
a thousand top level domains of where in
the year 2000 there was about 200 um
tlds
um the 200 tlds then were basically like
the dot com
like the five or six original um tlds
plus
the the tlds that were country codes the
two letter country codes
dot uk dot a you you know all those
and then they added 800 mo in the last
20 years mostly in the last 10 years
those aren't those are doing okay but
nobody's really making much money in it
from what i understand
um so you yes anybody can still get a
domain
if you if you don't really care what the
the suffix is what the tld
you're in but by reasons of prestige
it's because like the dot com years were
responsible for this
even the name dot com it was the
something dot com
what it means is that today if you're
some startup in silicon valley for
example
and you want to get like um you want the
food stuff or something and you want to
get like
ramen.com because maybe you sell like
indian food or something
i'll just say for that you'd like to get
ramen.com
but let's just say you go there you look
at somebody else owns it
and they want twenty thousand dollars
for it now
um maybe they want less sometimes they
could want more they can ask
they can ask whatever amount they want
now give you an actual number
business.com in 1993 somebody bought
that directly from
verisign for the first time and they
paid like back then that's
the standard price which is like 300 a
year something like that
um in 1999 at the time.com
it was sold for about five million
dollars
five million in at that time and yeah
it's something like that it's it's in
the records i do
but that's and and the price that the
the buyer bought bought it for the five
million dollars to buy a paid
was probably still a good deal because
since 99
the the dot the web has grown and grown
and you know like we added over a
billion people it
and yeah in india china europe as well
as america and so yeah you can imagine
so that's right and so right now
what we're doing is that we are selling
these linkages well
fifteen dollars that's one five and so
that's two or three orders banks you
cheaper than you can buy for
the dot com equivalent.com domain from a
domain
um how do they look right
so instead of like okay i use the
example ramen.com i don't really know
how much it's going for but
let's just say somebody i was wanting
like 20 thousand dollars that's about
reasonable up
the the equivalent lincoln it's just
robin the word robin in square brackets
that's yeah we're selling them for 15.15
um so it's three orders magnitude less
than twenty thousand dollars
uh but wait i have a question because
this is all about supply and demand
right i mean it's basically economics
you know the reason why
robin.com is high in prices because you
have a lot of potential buyers
so you're you so you you increase the
price but now let's say that somebody
buys from you for 15
the square brackets robin and let's now
now there's going to be a demand as
people transition to link it's instead
of the dot-com you're gonna be the
mainstream so
it's gonna be again a seller's market
right well
yeah um well we i think we're selling
too low right now but we are just
starting we
and so we have to price is one of our
main
advantages right now and later on we
will sell
oh but we also have a reserved list
because this is what
the domain registrars are doing today
already um
some of the domains right now um they'll
sell at high prices
we've a reserved list of words like
basically right now it's english words
certain words like um
intel which doesn't mean internal
corporation the chipmaker
it's just intel means intelligence like
military
so intel nobody so um so
we'll sell like the linker just intel um
the link it
oh computer that's all of these we
reserve
and we want to we'll start selling these
off like two or three years down the
road we'll auction it off
so we let we're going to let the market
decide and we
our reserve list right now is about 20
000 reserved linkers
we're going to grow that 100 000 because
we
since we do unicode we are going to use
like the word intel we will reserve that
in
french in italian and german and in
chinese
all of these so essentially right now
with domains with the domain
everybody's working in english basically
right now with
in linked it's in it's dictionaries in
every language so we can just do it over
again
and that's how we want to make our money
one day i think that's just a
that's just spectacular and so link it
i'm guessing it's a company that is now
running
and and it's is it actually active like
does it work that i can actually use
square brackets to go to websites
yeah i mean people can go on it they
they can apply and then
um if nobody has it then we'll send you
know that they can
buy it from us if it's not on our
reserve list we'll sell it to them
and then we've we have instructions
which are this is our alpha version
we've instructions on how they can if
they were
a coder if they were a you know computer
programmer
how they can like mod their web pages to
use the linkers
it's early days right now there's a long
way to go but right now
i'd like to think that right now it's
like in 1992 when you could buy
business.com for the first time
even if you didn't know how to write a
web page even if you didn't know html
just only because when you buy the
domain today even today
you still don't have to do anything with
it you don't have to put a website on
you can just own it
i remember uh we have an interesting
story my
my uncle box many years ago and
it obviously became very available and
actually and it actually
it actually prompted it him and his
partners to
start a company called choose.com which
later sold but
yeah it was it but i i just definitely
understand the value of domains
but wise i want to thank you for being
so generous with your time this was a i
love this conversation so much energy
and and i just love going all the way
back to the beginning you saying how
lucky you are to be in a place where you
feel like you're back in grad
school and yeah and and doing these
extraordinary research things and i just
love your passion and enthusiasm
so thank you for sharing that before we
leave the hardest question
i need three words that you would use to
describe yourself
intelligent inventor
engineer i love that wes thank you very
much
best of luck with lincoln i'm going to
go buy my own linkedin right now thank
you very much for everything
and stay safe and stay healthy yeah
you're welcome
thank you
you